hey guys let's do it B I'm in Chicago
next Friday Saturday Downtown Chicago
Frid have December 8th and 9th deep dish
pizza I'll be rocking my Yeezys December
8th 9th in Chicago then I'm in Nashville
January 25th one night only one show
then Austin the following Friday and
Saturday January 26 27 that's at thick
boy.com but Chicago see you next week
and by the way everybody Indiana if you
like Indiana if you live in Indianapolis
if you're in the area if you're in Ohio
Illinois whatever borders Indiana
December 7 8 and N I'm at The Helium
Comedy Club span Comedy Club the next
weekend December 15 16 the weekend after
that December 21 22 23 off the hook
comedy club in Naples Florida can't stop
won't stop and then as if that's not
enough I go to the Comedy Zone in
Charlotte North Carolina let's go for
New Year's guys you got to diversify
your economy in this D I need gold scog
my duck you got to diversify your
portfolio in this economy gold
co.com they have helped thousands of
people place over 2.5 billion that's B
billion with a B in gold and silver they
were rated A Plus by the Better Business
Bureau earned over 5,000 festar reviews
seven time Inc 5,000 winner and that's
just mentioning a few of their
accomplishments right now the fighter
and the kid listeners uh we are offering
up to $110,000 in bonus silver
oh.com go to
gold.com fighter to learn more just go
to goldco that's G ld.com fighter learn
more
yes
again this is really the fighter and the
kid come on baby you ready little bit of
a late start today see the thing is um
we decided to go grab lunch at airan
yeah and uh Brian was there before me
and so I rolled up you know I was doing
the shop show I'm like I'm hungry too so
I roll up I'm checking out and I hear
cling cling cling cling cling cling
cling cling what the hell is that I look
over Brian goes uh can I deposit these
here he's recycling no I was returning
the he's recycling cans and I go slowly
I go like I go no hold on I I said hold
on I go excuse me sir are you recycled
right now and the and even the old
lady's like okay I go hey B I'll if you
just want four bucks first you called me
you called me an unspeakable name yeah I
did you called me the lady you called me
an unspeakable name in front of the lady
and then I came back hey but I got a
bunch of cans by my house if you want to
come by later and just gather them up
and
I
feed well I feed my son a milk a raw
goat milk he loves it cuz it's super
sweet and it comes from his special farm
so he's obsessed with it well now you
ruin the whole recycle thing now you're
bougie as no no it's very very bougie
it's very bougie it's very expensive but
the bottles I get $3 back so I return
them so the milk is expensive but it's
clean clean clean clean clean you got
$14 CLE got $15 how was all what is
happening I thought just some random old
dude you know how it goes yeah those
have been sitting in my those have been
sitting in my trunk for since four years
ago uh my wife bought a bunch of glasses
for the for the uh kitchen I didn't like
them uh in fact I said these are the
worst glasses of all time so then she
she said return them and they've been
sitting in my trunk and I don't think
it's probably $300 worth of glasses I
don't think I have I can do it I don't
think I can't return anything I can't do
I can't return too much of a hassle I
can't I mean I can't recycle like that
when you look at recycling you know it
all goes in the same place right it's
all a hype well that's right yeah
Michael shellenberger said all that
plastic get sold to another country then
they throw it away into the ocean so I
throw all my plastic away yeah you know
what I'm saying bro at least you get
your 14 bucks man 15 oh oh dude this is
when I'm done with this you want me to
do you have like a bag or something you
want me to put this in there dude it be
cool all right I know times are tough
dude those are glass Bott still 5 cents
for the cans cuz I go through so many
DCS but they're glass bottles botles
they're old school glass bottles now I
spent Thanksgiving by myself eating a
large pepperoni pizza have we not talked
about Thanksgiving we haven't been in
here in seven days my God so weird long
longest break I've ever had you ate a
pepperoni pizza I my cuz my my uh my my
girl had the emergency C-section
unexpected [__] hit the fan so I spent
most of the time in the hospital and had
to go back to get all our stuff CU we
just rushed out of the house so I go
back to the house
and she's like well don't rush back
everything's fine here and uh the boys
at their grandma grandpa she's like get
the boys and just you know do
Thanksgiving at home okay and the boys
were busy doing something I was just by
myself nothing to eat order a large
Domino's piping hot pepperoni pizza I
just realized I thought it be cool you
had no Thanksgiving because Joe was in
the the hospital I thought it would be
fun I was like oh I've always wanted
Pizza on
Thanksgiving it was sad that's sad dude
very sad no no no turkey so so it was a
tough time yeah well what's funny about
that I I went through my own with my
wife she had a very complicated
pregnancy and so there was all kinds of
issues and what you realize is that uh
you're useless in that room huh like
thank God for w you realize nurses are
superheroes they're the [__] so are the
doctors in the niku in the niku the unit
man they are such badasses yeah such
badasses so my my child had my child's
heart stopped at one point my child had
real problems right my my wife's almost
died on the operating table so there are
a lot of problems right and U so but we
make it through but what was wild is
when you're going through those kind of
complications the
pediatricians they come in as a group
right they'll come in there's one main
one yeah they come in and if they leave
it's good it's all good if they stay
there's an issue and it was incredible
the
we one of the best ni units is one of
the best in country BL me it BW me I
spent a month in the I know I can't imag
I can't imagine but I thought because I
because I thought niku it's a preey so
she'll have to go in like the the
container like the alien spaceship I was
like y she'll be in there I didn't
realize how big of a deal it was and
then you know she they take her I follow
him to the room we go in there I'm like
all these are probably premies
everyone's fine and you're in there and
they hear beep beep beep and all these
nurses Rush In And they're doing this
thing and they put up the the the
Blinder so you can't look in I'm like
what the hell is happening yeah it's
pure chaos I'm like kid okay she's
sleeping I'm like what is going on here
and they're just like can you step out
for a second I'm out they don't let me
in for about 2 hours that baby passed
away a cuz in that in that area that's
like so I I didn't you know they don't
tell me much I didn't my baby wasn't in
a great state yeah you know cuz her
lungs weren't developed so she supposed
to cook longer she was like I need out
now and I was like oh this is cool she's
coming early it's not good when they
come that early no so they had she had
to go in that Nick unit for a while but
but hopefully she comes home today we'll
see yeah they dealth they deal with real
things you don't realize how big of a
deal and think about they deal with it
and I was talking to the doctor he's
like oh babies pass away every day he's
like people don't realize like certain
things happen oh yeah he's like thank
God your baby's breathing on its own it
start breathing on its own within an
hour sometimes when they're pries and
they don't have lungs it's tough or
they're not developed he's like it's
tough man he's like I deal with it every
day yeah like God you guys are badasses
they're bad asses I couldn't deal with
it and then the doctors they have a
doctor there for you as a husband cuz
they're afraid you might faint if you
see blood really yeah yeah so they
they'll for they'll be right near you no
what they do is they your cuck right get
get them James yeah you know you know me
out Macho they put me on thing they go
we may have to have a C-section the
baby's got to come out now then the baby
didn't and they they P pushed it out
there's a thousand things but they're
there with you in case you can't handle
it but I was like I I looked at the guy
and I were like this I go I go hey bro
get a cup of coffee I'm fine get a cup
of coffee I'm fine how are you doing
you're like a UFC judge take the night
off yep and you know what he said to me
he goes you're the one huh and I go some
would say the one that doesn't pass out
during the pregnancy yeah God hey guys
you need any help over there you guys uh
what's going on over there you you hear
those horror stories of like the
husband's passing out it doesn't cross
my mind me neither dude way to make it
about you she's
deing God you hear that I hear that and
I'm like hey bro I resent that it's like
you should out do stuff you got a
girlfriend I I am more awake I'm more
although I did sleep through some of the
more traumatic things I was tired I was
right in the same room in fact the
doctors go how is he sleeping through
this cuz there was a I can't believe you
can sleep yeah my my wife's blood
pressure like hit zero baby they I get
no sleep um Mr alert 24/7 but I was
there for some of it but one of them I
was asleep apparently when all hell like
50 people in the room out the guy the
guy literally goes how's he asleep my my
wife's like I I don't know he sucks yeah
he sucks he's [__] yeah he way to
show up oh but what I did watch what I
want to talk to you about when I was
eating my pepperoni pizza crying into my
pepperoni is I finally watched uh twin
flames oh dude how about that guy and
those those two that guy and girl how
about has anyone SE have you seen it
best for the viewers who haven't seen it
easy on cult right there's no evidence
of that so if you don't know twin flames
is a documentary on Netflix and it's
this couple who they say they're twin
flames they got within like 4 hours of
meeting each other he proposed to her on
Instagram uh DMS she keeps getting
bigger and bigger so they we'll get to
that so they and there's a reason for
that so there there's a couple that say
we found our twin flames we're going to
teach you how to find your twin flames
they start a club like a like a club on
Facebook they grow to 32,000 followers
he has the followers working for him he
tells him this is your twin flame this
your twinflame this 18-year-old girl he
goes have you I know who your twin flame
is I got a message last night right so
they're all in they have to pay $200 $
$222 a month just oh he's making bank he
FL his wealth $24,000 a month for the
for the whole course yeah to certain
levels minimum $222 a month 36,000
people are paying so he's making bank
every month but there's 18-year-old girl
he goes I get your twin flame he lives
in Salt Lake City she's like I've never
met him he's like I had a vision you
need to move out there right now all the
whole the whole crew pressures her she
moves down there this dude has no job
two Time Felon he's super abusive she
gets there and she's like this cannot be
real but she's trying to manage it she
was a very impressionable young yeah
she's she's 18 she even after finding
all this out she's like I'm still kind
of in this yeah she's like this is the
one there's a and then what they do and
this is where the cult similarities come
in is all Colts Colts do this they cut
off all uh uh communication to your
family cuz any normal person like this
is insane what are you doing so you got
to cut off all your family so there's a
mom on there searching for a daughter
hasn't seen her in three years yeah and
her twin sister identical Twi won't talk
to her no it's so hard it gets crazy
though cuz then Netflix yes cuz then it
gets crazy cuz as you keep going he goes
here's the thing there's no such thing
as sexuality so there's male flames and
there's female Flames a male can be a
female flame and a a female can be a
male flame so he was just like your twin
flame is a woman she's like I'm not a
lesbian he's like it's not about being
lesbian it's your inner flame so these
people weren't gay they were pressured
into getting with gay couples this guy's
incredible cuz this guy is he used to
sell a cure for cancer this guy is
classic he'd have a cell phone shop this
is the kind of guy that can sell
anything you know these guys just come
up with like ways and he's just it's all
marketing it's all packaging the best
the best is so he keeps branching out
he's an entrepreneur like a [__]
but so he keeps horrible person horrible
ter so he keep and so is his wife he
keeps making businesses out of it so he
goes I have my my diet plan to be the
perfect twin flame you got to eat like I
eat you got to he teaches you how to to
make them meals and you have to finish
everything guys and girls to pay for it
though you have to pay for it of course
give me a break so now he's like
branched off into meal prepping
everything no but you think it's like
it's all
car no it's all carb Likens himself to
Christ that's why the the girl the girls
put on an average of 80 lbs doing his
diet cuz you have to finish everything
it's all like heavy carbs potatoes and
burgers and like he don't know what the
f he's not a dietitian yeah but he was
selling this whole thing so every so his
wife throughout this my favorite part
the wife it should be called thick
flames the wife starts off at maybe 140
lb by the end of it is 240 and so all
the women are putting on they put on 70
lbs it's that one young girl goes I
gained 80 lbs it's so great whoa yeah
she just keeps getting way and and she
keeps getting quieter and quieter and
more and more in the background cuz he
shuts her down she would talk and he
just shut her he a classic cult leader
you know you can yeah this guy he's he's
look at her the poor thing how old is he
oh yeah young guy he's just he just
figured out a way to make money that's
all that's that's it's just his hustle
to make money and where it gets weird
too is when they got in trouble is he
wanted to buy a property a church and
have everyone live there and then start
for tax reasons for tax reasons but then
also he wanted to create his own
community so you he'd have sex with the
girls or he'd pick who you'd have sex
with to create these it's like LDS right
well Church lday saints a little
different similar concept it's no
different than what a lot of these
people are doing this is yeah Jo Jo Joe
Joe Smith but the Mormon church is has a
lot of really sustainable tenants to it
so a lot of it's like self-restriction
you don't drink coffee you don't drink
you know all they they they you help
people you have to be you have to help
Outsiders you go on missions uh they're
really really it's all about discipline
so the Mormon religion works for a lot
of people you're talking about po
polygamy no remember there was that uh
Netflix special like eat like pray pray
love no it was I know you that was a
different thing that but that's a SE I
didn't mean yeah there were certain
sects of that broke off from the [__]
Church which were abusive pedophiles but
he would pick who youu
with these are cult but those are
polygamous which is illegal sociopaths
sociopaths will will form followings
they're very good at like guys like Jim
Jones and stuff they're very good at
forming these these these uh Reinventing
a church Reinventing a religion they get
a cult and most of the time it's because
they want their dick sucked and almost
always they're having sex with all the
girls from the age of probably nine up
and that's the in that documentary it
was like nine but also think about they
had the wives on there when he go to bed
all six the wives had to line up they
were like we hated it and then they he
would decide all right you're staying
with me tonight and they'd be like oh
[__] wait who is this which on on this
documentary it's a branch of Mormon T
thing this guy he's more into money you
can see it all about money for this guy
it's not about sex it's he forces
employees to work for him and doesn't
pay
them I've had a boss like that but if
you see the employees you get it to it's
tough for them they they're all they
they they should be called twin warock
nobody's they're very lonely people very
lonely and nobody is attractive well you
know what he said he said it great he
said there are a thousand people on the
internet who who have a problem if you
can show up with a solution to that
problem there's a line out your door and
they just pay you this guy just figured
out a way to here's my question after
watching that if you're the feds if
you're the FBI yeah what did he do
that's illegal that's why they can't
come after isn't that crazy because it's
like with any religion Like You could
argue like this is insane this guy we've
never there's no evidence of it so if
you're the FBI like what he wants to do
like he's not doing anything illegal if
you're stupid enough to buy it like the
guy who sold he goes I have a solar
power dryer have you seen this he goes I
have a this is hilarious he markets a
thing and doesn't show you pictures of
the first ever to Market solar power
dryer so he's like please invest here
here's you know buy it here thousands
and thousands of people buy it you know
he sent them a hanger no it's solar
power dryer so great so the Sun hits it
it's a hanger so they want to sue they
go to the government they go to the feds
and they're like what he wants to do no
I see I think if you're stupid enough to
buy into this what do you can't this is
a guy this is a guy and there are a lot
of him out there he went you know people
are dumb and he's right and he said I
can get enough dumb people to pay me
money if I come up with a way to package
salvation or love or or or his thing
he's he's curing Lon he could guar yeah
he could guarantee you would find your
equal you'd find your twinflame would
guarantee it within a year and then he's
very good at coming up with these
different like tiers and packages and
classes we have to pay more and more
money to get to the top tier but then
also when twin flame so then he would
have couples who weren't doing well but
they were forced to pretend like they
were so people like well it works for
them so he must be doing something right
and then those people went bad on him
like this is all an act he used to beat
me and all this [__] like horrible stuff
look a lot of martial arts schools
before the UFC used to be that way a lot
of acting schools used to be that way
there was a lot of things like that
where your teacher is the end all and
Beall and you do everything and there
are people that just need to follow they
want to follow they can't CNN it's like
any CNN really I think people tune into
that and they think that's the gospel
it's like no they're just pitching this
stuff cuz they're getting paid man big
farmers paying them all this money
that's why they're doing it they don't
really give a [__] they're just paying
the stuff and then you repeat you parot
what they're saying it's all it's just a
it's just a Hustle but he said it there
you can there are people on the internet
looking for a solution to their problems
everybody is in pain everybody wants
something and if you're good and you
know how to come up with a quote unquote
solution if you people sell salvation
they sell love they sell immortality
they sell Health think about how many
people on the internet right now now are
selling you a way to live longer oh
selling you a way to raise your
testosterone selling you a way to have
more energy get more shredded this diet
this hype this diet this pill I mean
going to play on something play on love
right I feel like cuz everyone can
relate to him people are lonely as [__]
you feel bad for them like damn there's
one lady there like your twin flame is
Rebecca and it was this like military
lady she's like on camera she's like no
oh they're like well no we're telling
you we got a message last night from the
big man upstairs your twinflame is
Rebecca and she's like no just turn the
camera off she's like I'm out yeah I'm
not a lesbian so he pulls like higher
Powers into Oh's Towers well you know
there there are there is also a subset
of the population obviously that is
really damaged they're really a mess
they're they're mentally unstable
they're lonely when you sell when
whatever you sell I've done some sales
jobs and the one thing your sales some
anybody who knows how to train you for
sales will tell you is that there is a
segment of the
population that that can never say no
they cannot say no and those are the
people that's going to be your base
you're going to make money if you that's
why you have mail in ballots there you
go because you're too stupid this is
what they're teaching you're too stupid
to show up with an ID in person so they
want to mail it they want to make it as
easy as possible yeah yeah a government
IDE is apparently hard to get it's ins
you need it for everything it's so
insane um but yeah it was good yeah it
again I think you're right about this
guy what would you do with this guy like
to me I'm like look dude you're making
in my opinion I think this guy is a
complete fraud I think he's making money
off of people who are desperate I don't
think he's a good guy I I I would never
I would never narcist his hand but but
that's on the people he's taking
advantage of yeah if you're the
government like he's not killing anybody
he's not these people are doing on they
it's all via web he's selling you a
service that you're buying yeah are you
going to go after you know people that
read your poem yeah it's like the
government's like what do you wants to
do man if you're dumb enough you're dumb
enough to FAL syia Brown before she died
the great syia she used to make
$700 for 20 minutes of a phone call you
you said it would be 20 minutes you
would give her $700 this is back in the
'90s when people like where you know
she'd be like give me 700 bucks for 20
minutes I will consult with you and I
will I will I will give you a reading
and she made all the money well that'd
be like that'd be like trying to go
after an only fans girl' be like why
demon and she said she was into me it's
like yeah yeah you go after a stripper
too yeah yeah her name's not really
cinnamon either dumbass yeah you dummy
like you want the you want the police to
arrest the strippers it's a hustle there
was a whole thing Colombia guys who
would fall in love with girls in colia
and then go there send the money send
the money develop a relationship go
there and be like she's not here huh she
didn't meet you at the [__] train
station with a bow in her hair it's
called 90-day fiance if you watch that
you're like God figure it out yeah but
catfish you ever see that that that TV
show yeah I'm alive [__] some of those
people are just so desperate I don't
know how people get away with catfishing
anymore how do you not say let me see
your face not in 20123 especially cuz
that it's been a show for how long 10
years and there's so many ways
to I think it's still on though isn't it
it's still on people want to believe
it's like conspiracies it's way more fun
to believe that there's a conspiracy
in maybe something less sexy like oh I
don't know a
mistake yeah it started as a dock and
then branched stopped the entire series
that NE guy and his brother y the main
guy quit though the main guy quit no
ne's still on there the other his main
helper the the guy with the salty pepper
hair he left that one the shows the best
my least favorite people though are are
conman I hate conman I don't anybody who
likes him I hate him though I like I I I
would I'll take a murderer over a con
man anything oh not me a murderer yeah
like a guy who uh you know like some
people are just I'd get you know die I'd
rather get conned out of money than
die right guys figure it out these
gangsters gangsters a little Brave the
con man though like I I worked for a guy
like that and they have this amazing
what was his
hustle um you can't I can't say no no it
was a lot standup company like business
operation I I stopped having a guy on my
podcast back in the day soda Rogan
because there was a guy who was selling
uh he was selling health and yeah and
then I talked to somebody who ran his
company and and they told me how he how
he was running it and I went do I know
him yeah I was like that makes so much
sense do I know him yeah I'm sure you
would know him I'll tell you he's a
scumbag but so yeah but those people
when you get like the right people
together these guys know who to hire you
know they pick a girl who's like my only
other job was I worked at Hooters and I
drive a Toyota Corolla but I really
wanted infinity and like next thing you
know you're paying this girl 7 Grand a
month hell yeah and you own them where
is she going to go get a job like that
and they just Stockholm syndrome you
altogether those conmen are the scariest
people in the they're bad bad people
they're terrible they do what works you
know yeah cuz they sell some like I'm
connected to goodness stuff or whatever
for the hustle yeah they'll bring God
into it it's the best they bring
spirituality that's all cold start man
uhhuh
uhhuh they said there's like I forget on
that dock they said there's something
like over a thousand Colts in America
right now only it might it might be
2,000 yeah something like that but it's
a lot that you're like what like when
you look up how many active killers are
you're like what how's this not getting
more attention you have to have a leader
you have to have one person that's
really there with the answers up to
10,000 Colts that was way off type in
how many serial killers are chin is
there still like yeah active seral
killers in
America I mean well some Cults remember
the one remember the one where they all
dressed in purple Nikes and they all
they all drank they all died those are
black Nikes and Nike made them cover it
up yeah you're talking about the people
that were going to go to the he
castrated himself he
cast cuz they call those Nikes the
heaven Gates the Nike took them off
their sight now they're collectibles no
way the heaven gates are Collectibles
cuz they all died in those brand new
Nikes isn't that crazy and they they all
thought they were going to catch a a
comet they were going to catch a com
isn't that crazy and they said we all
have to die and go there that's the
Gateway the thing is there are
some like NASA scientists and [__] yeah
like Wicked smart people yeah they were
they did it in Orange count think they
were NASA scientists but there's I'm
telling there's some few smart people on
there well they they um shocking that a
lot of them were adults bring up the guy
at the Heaven's Gate leader of Heaven
gate his eyes are like yeah he had the
surgery he was a singer he the same
surgery you did yeah he used to be a
singer well he had no he had so I had
myg but he he had this you have this
yeah he had his eyebrows raised look at
him I'm trust anybody with that haircut
look at that guy poor guy what a mess he
cut his own balls off he had himself
castrated and then he uh yeah he sold a
whole Heaven's Gate thing yeah the
heaven gate Nikes his dad never his dad
kicked him out of the he was gay and his
dad kicked him out of the house and
never spoke to him again he was a singer
and he just he just he was lost that's
type in heaven gate Nikes J I want to
see the Nikes they're sick they you
can't get them anymore they ruined those
good thing they didn't do a cool pair of
kicks look at that purple and
black you would know the shoes dude are
these ones or which heav Gates guess so
those are sick why would they wear Nikes
oh cuz it you fly cuz Nike went to the
Sun or something absolutely not dude
just cuz they're popular sneaker they
could all buy at once what does Nike
mean in Greek anybody
anybody what's up what does Nike mean in
Greek I know I believe it means Victory
H yeah the original girl who got paid to
do it they they showed a bunch of the
logos that they she submitted it was
some young girl who went to Oregon and
she got paid like two
grand oh you're close Brian it means
Wing goddess yeah Wing goddess a victory
yeah
yeah if she got paid us not too
much do you know what company
Adidas is where it comes from what
country all day I dream about sex
Germany I think it's isn't it Italy no
Adidas Adidas is German I thought it was
Italian Adidas I I say Adidas it's all
day I dream about soccer but when you're
kids we'd say sex oo oh you don't want
to play this game Bubba right you're
better off with politics yeah yeah hey
stay in your lane stay in your lane D
sorry I apologize got a little carried
away right go recycle right hero it's
from herzo whatever yeah what does
adidas mean about
Sone doesn't mean anything does it Sone
is
Japanese no at all I love it oh all day
I dream about soccer oh [__] oh where
did I said that oh [__] oh well I just
said that twice you said sex didn't you
I could have swar you said sex I
corrected I said as kids we said that
see no one was paying attention I said
as kids we'd say that it was a fun thing
to say uh his name is AI doler no it's
actually it's not all dad dream no
that's what Americans would say that
because it lines up oh
Puma's German smoking okay that's all
stupid damn damn we saw a very gay
German man uh today walked by us he
went he yelled out he
was
I I was like that
is walking super straight up I was like
dude you're you're you're couldn't be
more stereotypically gay I mean and in
German I was like God when you're gay
breaks through through the language
barrier oh right away I went whoa like I
I couldn't understand what he's saying
in German but he was saying I'm a huge
fan of all the [__]
yeah I Can't Get Enough yeah I want to
dive into a sea of [__] yeah that's
exactly that's all I think about all day
long
yeah it was loud too I was like damn
literally like he was trying to get your
attention I said that I said that
Porsche got some salt and in sweet I
want to suck I want to suck the the the
Grease Monkey the grease the giant
grease monkeyy [__] the guy is dress
like a Mario Brothers
theer let me see your giant oer I want
the take
uner let me see your Hammer yeah he was
super flamboyant your truck is [__]
loud it's not for you man noise
pollution Ram trucks all noise
pollution dude you I was eating my meal
and I just
hear everybody everybody's like what the
[__] is going on Bo like he's just
sitting you were just it's like it's an
alarm for cucks they go running
especially at airan it's full of just
soft people they just vegans are like no
and you guys all ran I
knowbody going a jumpsuit with a bad
mustache and a mullet bigger than
everybody say something just big as [__]
just a bunch of Teslas I just want to
run over all them cauliflower ears with
a giant
truck it was actually I appreciate that
part yeah just Macho if you had had a
sword you come in and go everybody dies
today g g g yeah can it just doesn't fit
in
there
man if you want brenon to run away from
you really quickly just start talking
about fighting if you're not a fighter
don't ask me yeah yeah um espcially
technique I'm like should I waste all my
time on this or just a little bit you
know what I'm saying it's glad I'm glad
we're talking about meundies underwear
because I've had meundies for I don't
know maybe 10 years now and've while
they still hold up they if there's one
article of clothing now it's disgusting
that I've been wearing the same
underwear for 10 years but I can't let
them go because they still hug my Apple
Bottom it's the GI that keep on given
man they got all the black Classics they
got fun seasonal prints which I enjoy
especially the Christmas ones me has a
wide range of cuts that will fit your
style and your thick body but they're
also tense micro modal fabric okay is
soft as a warm hug for your for your for
your three-piece set breathable stretchy
this is why I wear them this that you
cannot argue with that fabric yep get
25% off your first order plus free
shipping go to meundies.com
tfatk that's meundies.com
tfatk for 20% off plus free 25 this is
insane 25% off plus free shipping meand
comfort from the outside the best in the
business when it comes to underwear
that's a fact um do you uh were there
any fights Benitas beat andr
Andrade yeah there's boxon fight yeah
what else you got well do you think that
you think canelo's ducking Benitas no I
don't but there's there's fights coming
up this weekend you have beer knuckle
you got Eddie Alvarez versus Mike Perry
which is phenomenal Edie Alvarez is a
lot smaller than Mike though isn't he uh
not really no Eddie Al Mike fought at 85
Eddie alv fought at 55 that that is a
significant difference 's a big thick
boy yeah he he is a little smaller damn
you got Deus with suian Armenian yeah
he's a badass yeah another [__]
Jaylen turn Bobby green Rob
font been at it for a while Sean Brady
Kelvin gastam it's a great fight night
it's really good damn Sean Brady Kevin G
play guid's fighting you m Misha still
fighting [__] he's amazing wait go back
go back go back Misha Tate's coming back
yep she's been back Bubba wow really I
think it her third or fourth fight what
I think third fight back yeah yeah third
fight she's one in one yeah
man there's a little
rumor H
GSP at 42 coming back I started that
rumor you did yeah that's where you got
that why did you start completely came
for me really cuz I had nothing to talk
about last Monday and your dumbass fell
for it so it's not not happening I heard
it from someone else of course oh son of
a ran sends me he goes look what you've
done [__] Rumor Mill [__]
goes look what you done he goes what
your source is I go nothing I go slow
Monday that's H now it's everywhere you
just were like GSP might make a comeback
why not um have you SE i l what he said
have you seen what's going on with the
Sean Strickland and Ian Gary stuff no
it's a a lot to get into I'd like to
hear it cuz I like I like that fight
even though I and Gary usually fights at
70 70 doesn't he 70 you were about to
say 75 I'm punch in the mouth y right
there's no Division I salute it I know
but there's no 75 division so you got
someu G's a big boy though tall you know
well then we're not talking about them
fighting okay what are we talking about
Chen do you want me to explain this like
a breakdown you explain it so Ian Gary
but someone sent me some notes go ahead
chin they were like we wish Jin would
look in a little more on these occurr
this is this is what I saw from the
internet so it's basically um Sean
strickling found out that Ian Gary's
wife she wrote a book 12 years ago
called how to be a wag and a wag is a
wife and a girlfriend of like a athlete
yeah like a professional athlete famous
athlete and then uh she he also found
out somehow that uh she has her
ex-husband living with Ian Gary and him
just confident and Ian Gary I guess he's
the the ex-husband is also the
nutritionist of Ian Gary this by way
this is all like stuff that they're
saying Gary Ian Gary is has nothing to
prove he he's confident enough but
they're saying that she's basically
controlling the stuff that he does so
and Sean Strickland made this these
posts like dude that's so lame I'm going
to teach you how to you know I'm going
to be a bro for you and like look out
for you don't be with that girl and then
there's stuff about them potentially
suing uh Sean Strickland because of the
stuff that you know he's saying so this
is what I got from I stay have all that
domestic [__] man yeah most Fighters
should this is what I got so the guy
goes the Ian gar store has been Twisted
it's all over online I wish you guys to
do a little more research uh he goes she
did release a 12 minute minute audio
book the term wag comes from the UK
media during the FIFA World Cup and it's
labeled all the football players Mrs
Wags The and ban the wax from traveling
with the football players during the
World Cup the living with her ex-husband
isn't real that's all been made up uh he
goes can you blame me and Gary though
she's a mil he goes this took me 5
minutes to find this out you and chin
please do better no by we're looking at
actual MMA articles and that that's what
they're posting We don't know the actual
details of we should Gary fights he's
all he's allowed to do anything he wants
like can I see his uh his wife Ian Gary
is a [__]
Warrior there she is Jesus good good
gorgeous I'd expect nothing less and
they and people are saying that she also
kind of like you know she's a little
older than him she's 40 he's 26 love it
oh love it [__] love him she's 40
yeah he just went up in my [__] book
she looks great I love that God bless
she's hot as [__] hell yeah hot as [__]
he's [__] aome Fu he a cute kid
that's I'm I'm a fan all the way around
and that's a yeah that baby looks just
like him too it's so cute Bravo Ian Gary
and Bravo to his hot wife and even sean
Strickland's like quote unquote best
friend Curtis he uh Chris Curtis he even
posted defend Ian Gary and his wife
saying like just leave them alone they
have their own relationship they're
doing their own thing like they're
actually good people this and that so
then him and Sean Strickland got we're
going Toe to Toe on on a it's all good
Sean's just Sean just
fire Curtis Sean's just a fire brand he
likes talk yeah but he's just a crazy
dude yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't think my
whole thing is is
um you don't know what's real what's not
like we don't like where this came from
who knows is it possible as far as like
them being
you know in this weird relationship and
all that stuff like we just don't know
can I float something what is it
possible that Ian G's flirting with
going to 85 no no he he doesn't want
this negativity okay I think he would
now yeah I I think that's what he should
do is try and beat up Sean Strickland
now be a good fight right but because if
it was if it was they're not just going
to [__] their way cuz him threaten
to sue him is not smart that doesn't
help anybody
mm yeah yeah so that's what the biggest
thing came from the whole lawsuit stuff
so that's why strickman's that's not
that's not Ian Gary that's his wife and
whoever else running his social media
like G did say something like I'm just
letting you know give you giveing your
heads up that you know this could be a
lawsuit but the wife is the one saying
like you know there's going to be
consequences if you don't take it down
which is already Silly by telling how do
we know Ian Gary said in the direct
message it was Ian Gary's I know I'm
saying that's not Ian Gary say got be
stupid think that's he came from his
account though I know I'm telling you
he's not running that that's coming from
saying came from his account that
doesn't mean [__] I've had a million
stuff come that so you think it's Ian
Gary no I'm just saying it came from his
account so that has to be and my message
to you CH is if you think that's Ian
Gary poting it who knows it could be
yeah we don't know it's not why you
don't know though you don't know for
fact you don't know you're not in charge
of his finger dude yeah you're not
people do post for you too right but you
also post yourself I mean so I'm saying
it could still come from him you don't
have guaranteed knowledge it doesn't
come from him I'm on your side I don't
think I don't think all right whatever
and I'm on your side yeah wish you knew
I'm just saying we don't know for a fact
that's the that's the truth we don't
know for a fact Ian Gary doesn't have
somebody running his social media well
maybe he does but it could still be him
posting too I don't know I like saying
stuff I like to mix I'm trying to stir
the pot here the problem is with his
marketing team it's gone so bad the
direction they've sent him he's getting
so much hate now it's been a nightmare
oh he was one of the most beloved
Fighters now they should hire they
should you should run a consultant firm
for fighters on social media and so
remember BR the we're talking about this
on shop show too like so he there's like
this I think UFC you know they do behind
the scenes stuff and then there was this
clip of Ian Gary putting on a shirt
versus a guy named Jeff Neil Jeff went
to prison a or went got arrest a long
time ago he had a mug shot so he put the
mug shot on the shirt but it seemed like
it was his wife's idea in the she did
all it she picked the shirt out and he's
like oh I love this he's like I wasn't
even thinking of this this is brilliant
but and you're just like oh what's going
on here so people yeah that's why people
are coming to the conclusion that they
think that his wife is it's very
possible she runs a lot of stuff very
possible there's a few Fighters like
that major Fighters that you know yeah
I'm sure and they don't run their social
media that's fine I remember when Mike
Perry used to have his girlfriend in his
corner you know yeah what's that have to
do with this same thing some people no
that's different CU she's not running
his social media and his narrative he
just had in the corner cuz he only had
one corner man and you have the love of
your life in the corner that's different
than her doing his PR and his [__]
talking for him that's a nightmare
nightmare that's that's CU now it's cuz
Ian Gary now it's he's gone again from
this beloved kid to just the most hated
guy in the
UFC because just the way they're
handling his accounts yeah not good it's
not his fighting is insane he's so
talented so he's taking care of the
business there then outside of the O you
want people speaking in your voice he
can I did that in way in the beginning
somebody took over my social media you
me both and it's a nightmare they were
making jokes and stuff I was like who
wrote this this isn't oh it's a you're
like this is not I would never say this
or post it yeah I learned my lesson with
that you just can't yeah you're better
off not having social media than having
somebody that's not authentic running
for you this long this can't remember
who the [__] was it was it it was it I
was with uh I was with a management firm
and they took it over I remember that
they were making jokes I remember
that you guys remember that it was like
something about me being like from outer
space and I was like hey dude this is
not my kind of humor please don't try to
be funny in my voice cuz that's not
going to work you're not going to ever
you're not going to do that it's
disaster yeah like you're a comedian
yeah yeah it's it's not they thought
they were helping but I was like oh they
mean well but it was just some guy who
was like ah let me try this I was like
hey this you're better off just maybe
posting once a month or once a week than
to have somebody run it every day yeah
it's not
good I do always wonder that how many
like comedians run their own social
media cuz some of the stuff that gets
posted you're like this doesn't really
align with them with like only fans too
I hate to tell you fellas you know the
actual attractive girls not answer in
back they have managers entire team that
answers just their DMS remember
Hollywood was run this way your
publicist would do all your talking for
you if you were an actor like Robert
dairo and you know what's really
interesting about with the internet
before the internet became what it is
people like dairo and Brad Pit and
Angelina Jolie or any of these actors
they they would only be in the public
eye for five minutes at the most at a
time un unicorn so they'd come on and
you'd be like holy [__] I'm going to
watch Nero he'll say a couple things on
Carson you didn't know his politics you
didn't know his view on women children
nothing what Cari drove you just saw him
for that five minutes on Carson like oh
my God he's so cool yes now you find out
that you know Arnold is vegan or
whatever and you're like what everything
you see the W it's not good it's not
good yeah or or like you'll have uh I
remember when gu Brooks decided to get
on Facebook do do you remember that no
you don't remember when G Brooks Brook
said I'm going to get on Facebook you
can see it it's very interesting to
watch cuz he was he just was out of
touch with what people were well think
the best example think if Britney Spears
didn't have social media she would be
the Scarlet I mean she would be the
biggest thing ever right here I want you
to watch video yeah watch
this well I guess it's official we're
now on Facebook I really wasn't sure
about this at the start but then a
friend of mine said something that just
made all kinds of sense she said think
of it more as a
conversation I like that but I'm already
finding out on my own so it's wiping the
walls out between you and me and I
really like that it allows us into each
other's worlds or I I guess in my
case hotel
room when I think about things I want to
post I want to post cool stuff slick
stuff neat stuff cool stuff stuff I'm
going to post is going to be raw stuff
like this this is the guy that was
running my social media I post raw stuff
sweet Tru a conversation then I say let
the conversation begin
y That's the cringiest video I've ever
seen my life I want post cool stuff
slick stuff raw stuff how about that and
then go go to Al remember when Alec
Balwin asked his followers to follow his
wife yeah no it went real oh oh and I
love Alec bwin I love him but dude when
these actors decide they to get into a
SP it's like i' hey I'm the same guy
I've I've done watch this hey everybody
it's
December do that again hey everybody
it's January
5th uh the day before my wife's
birthday it is my wife ilaria's birthday
tomorrow January 6th he's still good can
attach the same significance to January
6th that other people do we just say
it's ilaria's birthday um I would like
to ask you a favor I would like to ask
you a small favor this did not go over
my wife is just it seems like she's just
centimeters
shy of uh um a million followers on
Instagram and I would like to ask you as
a birthday gift or even just gesture to
my wife would you follow her on
Instagram she got lit up so bad
obviously I love my wife obviously I'm
crazy about my wife obviously blah blah
blah a say about people we're in love
with uh he's a good guy fabulous he
killed a person yeah whole life that's
true he shot a person sure come on true
I he did yeah straight up did it me too
sure [__] dude the did like that's the
kind of stuff where you're just like
dude you are used to a camera someone
should just like no no no no you don't
want to do that cuz it's not going to go
the way you're thinking but again
imagine how bat crazy Britney Spears
looks now if there if she just decided
not to do Instagram and just we'd think
she's normal we'd be like dude she's
still crush it she'd be out in the media
like oh we love Britney but now we're
like dude there's Britney she's bat [__]
crazy it's hilarious to me well Britney
Ison Britney has uh yeah Britney does
have um mental health issues yeah um but
[__] your social media can be a tough
thing that g Brook's one's the best I've
ever seen I'm posting raw stuff real
stuff slick stuff cool stuff so he's
like like here for me hotel room I'm
just like you guys one time I called s
breaking down the wall text Sasso and
deia when we were doing 10-minute
podcast and I said hey guys can you
tweet
to I said hey guys and I was dead
serious I go guys can you tweet to my
people to buy tickets for my show in St
Louis or something and they
go what and Sass goes Chris please
explain to Brian why this is a very
stupid thing to text us no my favor is
Rogan when when you'd ask him to post
your dates back in the day he goes He
we'd be in a group chat R goes did you
post it Brian Brian goes no he goes I'm
sure it's [__] no I I said hey brid he
goes how are you gonna tell me to post
them when you haven't he say to me he
goes just let me know and I'll tweet it
for you I go okay hey can you tweet that
I'm GNA be he goes he goes where is your
post about it I was just going to
retweet it I go I didn't I didn't post
what so I'm not posting Jesus Christ you
can't do it yourself I'm not doing it
it's so
funny yeah social media is a weird thing
people do some how about remember when
uh was it Troy Aman who or was it
thought he was dming he was married at
the time thought he was dming W he's
like what's up girl about to land you
ready for this [__] foot long and
then everyone respond back like y yo yo
I want to bring it up I don't want to
call they're like yo yo y yo this you
thought this is going to be a DM this is
everybody can see this man he just
delete was like my bad my bad baby oops
oops it is what it is someone's older
you know it's just when you're older
it's tough man it's tough at 40 that
[__] Works 50 60 years old well my my
thing is I know people who have all the
money and everything else and they care
about their followers and I'm like dude
I don't get it if I didn't have to do
this you can I mean you'll know I've
made enough money when when you just go
to search me on Instagram and I'm no
longer available Brendan made it that's
right Bubba yeah I'm out Bubba that's
right soon as I reach a certain
Milestone your boys out and you know
what I'm just picture my be that without
kids right yeah or no kids or not I
don't give a [__] I just post pictures
of my [__] so I get
banned have a good day but not
basket after like a workout after a
workout raw just sitting there like a
dead baby bird just Bo like that you
think I'm at the fish market leave on
the chair like this think I'm at Pikes
Fish Market you're like this dead and
your dick is like this yeah and I just
like Brandon R and there's going to be
two raw fish here and then it's there
you're like this though
and I'm going have money coming out my
mouth and then it's then I'm going get
banned on Instagram now I would do this
I would stick literally as much money as
many do is there such thing as a $1,000
bill no no okay so just $100 bill how
about half dollars up your ass no $1,000
$100 bill is a as much what just stuck
right up your [__] see if you can
find that I'm sure somebody stuck a
bunch of money in their [__] no we
remember we looked that up and it was
whoa what oh $100 yeah issue bill is
larger than okay too bad it used to be
$10,000
bills oh 10,000 make $500 bills anymore
and they still may still be in
circulation you could find $5,000 bills
no do a do a million dollars in cashier
check and just stick it up your pee hole
ah sticking out of your dick hole going
this really hurts but this feels better
say thanks for the good
times I'm out just your [__] just a
picture of your [__] with the money
popping out and for no reason Rogan
Eddie and my face near at the way we do
the werewolf oh that'd be cool right
yeah something like that we'll think
it's something somebody said to somebody
said to me I saw you uh and a bunch of
other older gentlemen around the
werewolf and I went wow we are older
gentlemen cuz we're all gray friend said
I saw you and a bunch of other old guys
oh dude I was at a carnival with my with
my son with all his classmates and
there's like teenagers there cuz
teenagers they're like oh dude you're
the guy from Tik Tok right I'm like what
yeah man on Tik Tok I'm like I guess how
old are you guys like 14 I was like oh
okay you're still young 40 is still
young though yeah I guess you're 16
years younger than me dude I know what's
wrong with me I don't know Peter Pan huh
kind of thought it was fun not to grow
up until I H to he guys fun thought it
was fun all fun and games [__] hits you
yeah it's all good though it's all good
baby I love my baby cool man what do you
got chin
I thought it'd be fun to play a little
bit of a game with you guys just a
little how was your how was your
Thanksgiving it was good it was nice we
friends giving yeah I went to friends
giving I not family no no we didn't do
family stuff this year well yeah but it
was it was good a lot of loving people
so why are you being all uh koi about it
it do seem like it went good was it I
did like was it a drug fueled no damn DG
no it wasn't it wasn't actually yeah but
I feel like there's something going on
with you there's something romance wise
going on cuz you're being a little bit
cor I know no it was a good but you're
going like this no I'm not it was good
are you the cult leader from [__]
twiname you find your twinflame is it a
lesbian the search continues Brian
really yeah all right all right what do
you got chin oh just a couple questions
for you
guys so last week you know you guys were
telling me the importance of dates and
geography and all that stuff so I'm just
curious real quick we'll start with
Brendan uh your mom Jen is this your way
of getting back this is just a fun thing
we're doing here s very fun dude well
find out so wait you said your mom's
from England right yes so you're half
English basically so who's the current
prime minister of the
UK oh cuz they let homeboy go right oh
[__] there's King Charles right now no
no it's not King Charles the prime
minister right no I know I'm saying the
king there's a king cuz the queen died
yeah but that's the prime minister
that's no I know I'm a weir brine I'm
just talking out loud for [__] sakes so
the king and then the Prime Minister
isn't it a chick now no is it not a
female nope it was Boris Johnson it was
Boris Johnson they got him out of there
I don't know it's kind of a it's a it's
a tricky one I don't know I wouldn't I
wouldn't know the name if you said it
all right so anyways we'll go back to
that but uh Brian you were born in the
Philippines y who's the current
president of the Philippines well it was
Duarte right okay I don't know who it is
now I don't know who it is you don't
know it is no no okay no Z don't look at
me you're Persian
right yes who's the current Chin's way
of getting back at you want to go World
War II [__] is the current prime
minister of I'm I'm actually attaching
it to things that are close to cuz I got
uh the Korean war wrong right so that's
what I'm saying I say I thought it was
the late 40s but whatever who is a wait
the person running uh wa we what was the
name of the prime minister in England
yeah right now it's like a Rishi sunak I
think it's a Indian guy yeah yeah I
can't uh and so with he can't your phone
whatever D I'm not going to put her on
the spot listen I don't he's a
conservative he's a Tory right he's a
isn't he of Iran no no no of England the
Prime Minister labor and Rishi sunak
okay that's right I speak yeah he's
pretty cool he he's cons leader of the
conservatives yeah he's an interesting
guy man to hear him talk but I Fu keep
going CH should have known that oh oh
actually I was going to ask
you why I was going to ask you the
president of Mexico oh that's why
because you're also your wife is Mexican
and your kids are half Mexican I just
wonder I don't
touch I don't know they I don't it's
Andre last time I remember was vente Fox
that's ando's kids
Andor a lot of the stuff I guess is it's
it's hard for me to know the name yeah
dude sometimes it happens though you
know what I'm saying but chin can I just
beIN when it com to world history oh God
there we go between a floating you were
born in the Philippines listen there's a
difference between a floating Head of
State in a country because it's always
changing not relevant what M what does
matter is knowing the seismic events in
history oh boy that's all I have another
game for you guys oh Jim was embarrassed
that's what this was your point today I
told him I told him not to be
embarrassed Because by the way Brian
said dude you could delete all that I
said what I say Brian yeah I said no I
said my point was that a lot of times if
it's not relevant to your life you're
not going to know it I said I I use my
time to build new skill sets and stuff
that I actually passionate about yeah
nor nor do you have to have time to
focus on that with everything we're
doing awful so it would make sense but
this is just a little fun thing cuz I
honestly don't remember all the states
but if you guys want to do this just put
the abbreviations oh that's a
[__] and we'll fast forward it
so the fans don't have to see us doing
this yeah should be all right at this I
don't don't look your phones gets a
little W in the middle oh I'm I'm this
is a tough one come on Brian Brian I'm
putting all my money on you for this one
well I don't
know it's kind of tough and we'll fast
forward this to the end so the fans have
to watch us doing that okay
but no dude [__] hold on hold on Don't
Talk To Me Hold on Ohio Illinois hold
on God damn it I got Kansas I think and
it better not be where I think but it
might be there it might not be there I'm
[__] up right now where's some other
names over there if you were to ponder
over there on tour where are you talking
about you know just east coast in
general right East Coast in general you
got you got New York you got
Massachusetts you got Vermont you got
New Hampshire Main Island Slow Down slow
down got Connecticut [__] you got New
York and
Pennsylvania huh [__] a lot of things
you got you got pyl Virginia and West
Virginia [__] you understand I think we
should put a timer on this cuz it's
going to take forever okay we can go
give us five more minutes five more
minutes one more minute one more minute
yeah we give us one minute all right one
more minute now if I was to leave
Illinois 30 seconds and jump on over to
the right that's a good question and I
was going to vote yeah who where am I
voting at well you know you have your
choice between Illinois and Missouri
right so now that's where where I put
Missouri and Illinois is atrocious and
I'm probably going to be very [__]
embarass I'm be pissed off of myself but
I don't care cuz I'm an [__] I don't
even know what the virginas are yes
virginas I think I know oh I don't have
the virginas on there but I know that's
some country bumpkin up there 2 one one
minute all right can you sign it guys I
Lally just put Virginia in there and now
the grades are in how do we do okay uh
Brendan you got 29 States right out a 50
it's not bad dude not bad and Brian you
got
31 yay I got 29 you got 31 31 that's
pretty pathetic by the way that's not
great son's got 40 just kidding shut up
I did not I didn't even count mine 31
States I didn't get any and I what did I
get wrong my game what did I get wrong
um fuckingg inverted Georgia and
Alabama both swapped those South is
tricky yeah it is but I'm going to say
Brian you were really impressive you got
Vermont Rhode
Island up there well okay I thought he
was from never mind um and you got
Delaware yeah you know did really good
there the Virginia you guys both messed
up yeah don't count I guess not have
seen that when you're in the the mix
with these tiny little things I can't do
it I still can't even looking Kentucky
Brian you didn't know where Kentucky was
been there where was Kentucky where I
put Kentucky did I get Tennessee right
you got Tennessee right yeah I would
hope so dude yeah Tennesse did I get
Missouri
right I believe you did right here I
don't think I did you no no you you did
not did I get Illinois and Ohio right or
Missouri was Illinois yep and then you
forgot Indiana damn [__] that area is so
hard Missouri Illinois I'm still looking
at it Missouri Illinois Indiana Ohio I
can't get it right you guys are pretty I
got Ohio right didn't
I Ohio's easy no I got no you got Ohio
wrong wow you're stupid Hey holy [__]
Indiana's right there [__] dude you
majored in American history Illinois and
Indiana I know I've driven through both
I've driven through [__] I should
have known that Ohio and Indiana were
[__] I've I'm lucky I just drove to
Arizona cuz that one was throwing me for
a
loop but and I've been to the Four
Corners it's so overrated thanks not 31
29 good yeah it's not bad actually I'll
take listen I'll take 31 he did not
seeing them straight off the top of the
Dome dude I mean it's just what you get
into the Illinois Ohio I don't know I
I'm just terrible with that stuff hey it
happens guys it happens you know oh
that's Chin's way no you still don't
know world history this is a fun it was
a fun game right chin you son of a [__]
you know what chin You're A Silent
Assassin no no no I saw the but I saw
for a mile ass as soon as I want to play
a
game Koreans Will Wait Koreans they like
Koreans Will Wait being honest 10 years
for a Korean is a very short period of
time you guys would have all destroyed
anyway Koreans Will Wait a generation to
get back at you don't [__] with Korean
he waited one [__] show it's a long
time Bubba he waited years he wait till
we back in studio waited like this he
wait till we back in studio he was in
his he was like this he was at his
apartment going can I think of [__] he's
like what don't they know [__] he's
like Brian embarrassed me on [__]
camera no hey remember Bri you said you
could take it out like no we're not I
don't I don't like that gotcha stuff cuz
it has nothing to do with any you're
just not it's not relevant to you it's
not a big deal it's like the president
of the Philippines not relevant to me a
Filipino very relevant yeah to me I'm
like I don't know even the even the UK
it's not like World War II is a major
don't feel bad they have a rotating
prime minister and I know he was a a
conservative but I didn't know his name
hey guys sometimes we get stuff wrong
you know hey wow look at this all right
uh so we we talk about Airlines a lot
and common decency and look what
happened on Frontier you guys I'm right
here sorry everybody are you
serious I don't give
a
you I got to
go this is
America America look at that guy just
kind of like honest uh West Virginia
this poor little boy
to they want to let her pee she must
have had to pee so bad well they should
let a woman pee not in the middle of the
[__] aisle D if that lights on
respect that light no you got to pee you
got to pee [__] I've had to go so bad
but also there was a guy who took a [__]
on the cart cuz he had really bad
diarrhea and it was all down the aisle
that was disgusting okay y you know how
bad it's getting if you got to do that
now homeboy got
a DI on him and a and a body so this is
the issue with gray sweatpants gentlemen
don't wear them in public I think it's
great record wise hold on you can lose
late you think only those pecs are the
only thing popping you don't think he's
a freak all over home boy a stud a he
game I mean he's probably defense player
of the year you have your Desy your
hands don't control it don't don't allow
to so let me get this straight he's got
speed and a dick I'll Club you man how
tall is homeboy he's 65 yeah miles
Garrett the open Locker cont that needs
to aim completely inappropriate who said
that what donut said that exactly some
dough
oh this one too uh if you guys are going
to take your kids to Disneyland this
this holiday season be a little worried
but it's on the Small World ride which I
could use the excitement that thing's
brutal yeah dude but the guy completely
stripped down naked oh no he's still in
his chony no so later later yeah I'll
show you the video we can obviously put
on oh he thought that was water is he a
little crazy I think he's high
yeah I guess they said he was on drugs
like but here's the naked one well
that's what happens when you do too many
oh he goes down the water
slide hell yeah yeah he's not doing too
well dude on Splash Mountain also his
ass looks super dirty he's got no ass do
it on Splash Mountain look at that
little dong that R so slow so you don't
have to worry about he's not he's not do
that on the matorn [__] he's not well
Disneyland needs a lot of security who's
that guy why he just like talking in his
why that guy dressed like Will frell
from The Elf oh damn They Carried him
out like that ass first oh that's that's
is not good that's good by the way
that's Rock Bottom that's Rock Bottom
when you're being carried out like a
dead squid and and you're like this and
you're naked and your dick is flopping
that guy drives a Tesla and recycled yes
look at his little shitty look at his
little [__] open they just open his
[__] for the world to see that's the
type of guy go your truck's too loud
look at his look at he's got no quads
things haven't worked out for you poor
guy he's probably got mental illness is
that Mr Burn's flat ass yeah it's a situ
but why would you have a freak out at
the on the small world you have to start
with his mother and the chemistry and
his bra but why go to Disney and freak
out yeah do at Six Flags if you're a man
do on the glosses bro he's probably on
drugs we
kind uh here's another fun one guys Dave
pornoy has decided to make barol a
reality TV show it moved to Chicago too
employees our boy Wills on
this winner gets
$100,000 in cash you give me $100,000 in
cash I might be dead within a week or
I'm going to have the very best time
ever they'll live sleep and compete here
survive in advance we're built for the
trenches out
here oh my God you're sleeping in here
yeah I'm living in here horrible Rico
just dropped this one on us but he gets
night terrors your of
friendship camaraderie and bad blood has
all led to this get the [__] out of here
you're [__] [__] [__] anything
go begin game you're running a [__]
[__] game do your job
better do your job better [__] Jeffy
wild and that is [__] Insanity not my
bar we're going to make that rule up get
the [__] out of here every person is
that his brother stab me hopefully we
don't get there Tommy's the first
because we got get Tommy out Tommy I'm
going to vote for Tommy this is the most
in trouble I think I've ever been you
get mixed up in this game and there's no
chance your feelings don't get into it
Steven really oh wait that's Fu stabbed
him in the
back will that's your friend that's my
boy yeah I love will super close love
will yeah see what happens it sounds
good just I'm a little bored right now
but it sounds like no not that I don't
have anything to say f i just no it
looks fun I just talking about it I'm
not sure cuz I show you how much money
they've made where they started doing
reality shows killing it okay so I saw
this just pop up that Oscar storus going
be relased the guy with one leg who
murdered the beautiful two thighs no
like both of his legs are oh yeah both
of them he uses mechanical legs so
gorgeous dude I know and so even as so
he's going to be released and I guess
he's in like a it's he's going to be in
a house whatever so it's yeah but um
Olympics
2024 but even like her mother her
mother's so pretty her mother why did he
kill her he said he thought she was a
burglar in in the bathroom which is such
bull the bathroom have you watched the
dock I it's tough even the mother says
like she forgives him for some reason
but she says she doesn't believe a story
and she doesn't believe you know that he
thought it was a burglar yeah the only
way to move forward is to forgive I'm
surprised he get out of prison for that
like 10 years huh 10 years a long but
it's South Africa so but he killed his
someone murdered my aunt they only got
six this guy has no legs and did 10 why
why would they get six baded
Insanity okay yeah she is good good good
gorgeous was gorgeous good God yeah she
was what a
shame um I don't know how much you guys
car about this but I'm out what else we
got I would have watched this oh did you
see Dolly Parton at the Cowboys game
she's 77 years old and she dressed up as
AOW Rockets out see them Dolly tits
she's amazing yeah she's crushing it did
you guys watch the Jack harlo halftime
show
no hell of a songwriter was bad bad
reviews what was it Jack haro's they
said it was cheesy it looked like he he
came out of an
eggloo it was bad Dolly crushed it what
is this uh so Sean Strickland had posted
a a video earlier about someone that he
thought was stealing his car then he
updated it this one's the most recent
one and it shows what he did to the
guy is that had his property so Sean
thought he was robbing his house taking
or trying to steal his cars Sean strick
is born for
this look at him the music I know I
can't play the music so I just works out
like Michael Myers oh my God does Sean
have a gun yeah yeah and there's a guy
walking away and then Shawn does boom
drops him did him no no no he didn't
shoot him Jesus
Sean but this is what he always wanted
you know he he wants type of stuff oh my
God don't [__] with so the guy was
arrested he's like Liam n from
drunk and so this is what he says was
drunk apparently stomping out a girl and
the security guard saw it he jumped in
the car drove off security security
guard followed him hit a curb completely
shorted his tire drove off the rim for a
while and then tried to hide out at
Sean's house
wow yeah that's the worst guy's house
Sean strick's like what are you
doing um let's just do one more this one
here so apparently this this influencer
on Tik Tok they found her trying to look
like she's cleaning up the beach so I'll
play this for you something from it
maybe we can all learn something from it
yourself hey without further Ado let me
get to the video actually and here we go
enjoy take care how to look like you
care for the environment part one get
your friend to film you filling up
rubbish
bags with
sticks it it this is great I bet part
two now pull off an Oscar winning
performance of you struggling in the
wing
ah this is so
great part three celebrate your Good
Deed by doing a shitty
Dance part four leave rubbish bags
behind
what what a piece of [__] the bag there
yeah oh they even collick the bags
that's the diciest part about sounds
like a way to go you [__] that it
that's it for clicks guys I'm going to
say this right now you come see me in a
place called that you can't find on a
map Indianapolis that I cannot find on a
map he doesn't know December 7th 8th and
9th at Helium Comedy Club span Comedy
Club December 15 and 16 and then off the
hook Comedy Club December 21 22 23 and
Comedy Zone yeah that's right December's
busy December 28th 29 3031 don't forget
guys I'm also going to London this this
week to do some hunting with Tim Kennedy
and my buddies about waste of time come
on buddy we're gonna do some uh this
week when I leave uh tomorrow night I
don't know what we're GNA do we'll
figure it out can we do a oh and I'm not
here podcast
tomorrow how many how many gold hours do
we have two I think I think one so yeah
we'll we'll figure it out yeah uh I'm in
Chicago next week next Friday Saturday
only Chicago two Friday two show
Saturday I got Chicago riding the map so
suck it I'll be eating deep dish pizza
in Chicago December 8th and 9th
Nashville Tennessee keep on trucking
tour continues January 25th one night
only in Nashville then that following
Friday Saturday I'm in Austin January 26
27th tickets at thick boy.com all right
kids love you